former Surgeon General dr. Vivek Murthy
tackled a range of public health crises
they included issues like Zika drug and
alcohol addiction and obesity but he
also shed light on a silent crisis the
rising number of lonely people in
America he spoke about his concern at
the Aspen ideas festival last year many
people I have met have thousands of
friends on Facebook but find few people
who really know them as a society we
have built stronger Wi-Fi connections
over time but our personal connections
have deteriorated now in a Harvard
Business Review article moorthi writes
loneliness is a growing health epidemic
he calls on companies to make fostering
social connections a strategic priority
dr. Vivek Murthy joins us back at the
table it's good to see you again
thanks great to be here now this is a
topic that you say that you know
personally about you said that you were
a shy lonely kid that people didn't even
know that about you that's true you know
in fact it's something I've never even
talked to my own family about but when I
was a child I was very shy it was hard
for me to make friends and I felt lonely
a lot but I felt ashamed to tell that
lie the shame yeah well for many people
and for myself when I was a child and
many that you're lonely is essentially
equivalent to admitting that you're not
worthy of being loved that's really what
underlies this stigma around loneliness
so why is loneliness now an epidemic
well we are recognizing that loneliness
is a lot more prevalent than we thought
it was but the data is also showing that
there are more adults who admit to being
lonely now than just two decades ago and
there are several reat possible reasons
for this number one people are more
mobile now than they ever have been
people move away from their communities
and their home their record numbers of
people who are actually living alone but
we also know that technology has had a
potential role here technology can help
her hurt it's simply a tool but for too
many people technology has led to
substituting online connections for
offline in-person connections and
ultimately I think that has been harmful
looking at your phone instead of talking
to someone exactly or spending time on
on Facebook or another social media
thinking that that is equivalent to
sitting down and seeing a friend and
talking to them face-to-face
more common in men than women well they
did is interesting on that but we reason
to believe it men may be more at risk in
some ways for loneliness and some of
this has to do with our culture around
masculinity no we think that masculinity
is is tied to being self-sufficient and
not expressing your emotions and
certainly not admitting to feelings of
loneliness but many men do feel lonely
especially after they get married or
have children where their social circle
is narrow women are much better at
keeping their connections in life than
men are doctor I think the interesting
point you make too though is the
connection between loneliness and our
health and real health issues that occur
as a result of it this is one of the
reasons that loneliness is getting more
attention because we are learning more
and more about the impact on health it
turns out that loneliness is associated
with the reduction in your lifespan that
is as severe as a reduction I spend that
you see with smoking 15 cigarettes a day
it's greater than the impact on
mortality of obesity and part of this is
because that loneliness actually places
us in a stress State we evolved to be
social creatures and thousands of years
ago if you were connected to other
people you were more likely to have a
stable food supply I had to be protected
from predators so when you're
disconnected you're in a stress State
when that happens chronically it can
have a profound impact on your health do
companies invest it mean is it worth
building in more time for folks to get
together like CBS News there's a walking
Club right now and they used to be like
coffee breaks right the people take or
even happy hours you know where everyone
gets together is do you think more of
those times need to get built in I think
the quality of time that people have
together is what matters again giving
people time to get together during happy
hours that can help to some extent but
sometimes people feel that they're just
getting taking time away from family or
they're taking time away from the work
day if they do and what do they end up
doing often talking about work that's
what they have in common yeah instead
providing dedicated time in structured
settings for people to truly get to know
and understand each other what are their
values what drives people what are their
experiences and inspirations and what
are their lives outside of work people
hunger to be known authentically and far
too many people feel invisible right now
and that is at the crux of our
loneliness that I think would be hard
for anybody especially an adult male or
female to admit I'm
and and what are you supposed to do with
that if you're feeling that way well
it's a great question so number one is
to recognize it if you are feeling
lonely you are not the only one there
are many people out there who are
feeling lonely number two if you're
feeling lonely that does not mean that
there's something fundamentally wrong
with you and that you're not worthy of
friendship or being loved and finally if
you are not feeling lonely it's
important to recognize they're very
likely or people around you who are and
that's why it's so important for us to
reach out to them the fundamental thing
is this we have for years thought about
ourselves as an individualistic society
the champions
individual achievement but what the data
around loneliness tells us now more and
more is that we are truly interdependent
creatures now and that ultimately we
need each other this message I do write
I think it's really good
dr. Murphy thank you so much thank you